dodgers and the cubs game
three as they wrap up this series and
the cubs go for the series
sweep here's bets now owls of ideals
in there got him looking and bets knew
it al zolai off to the fast start
well i'm sure rookie betsy said hey they
said this kid loved to throw a slider
and rosalie crosses him up with a two
seamer
max muncie the batter two outs in a man
at first
the pitch to muncie swinging a missed
strike three
the inning is over alzalai puts a zero
on the board
walker bueller had a no decision his
last timeout
and his last 21 games now that's 21
starts including the postseason
no loss 6 and over the 268 going back to
september of 2019.
he strikes peterson out with a fast ball
at 97.
one away here's chris bryant got him
with a fastball back-to-back strikeouts
to open the day on that pitch
for the last two starts walker has
struck out 19
guys the ultimate boom or bus
hitter it's been more of the goods
hitting above 300 with four home runs in
his last 10 games
he strikes out in a fastball and mueller
strikes out the side
three fastballs to put away the top of
the cubs order
nothing nothing game there has not yet
been a base hit and the batter now is
chris taylor
got him looking nice pitch there and
taylor
is gone how about the pitching on both
sides here i think this slider that he
has developed and the command and
confidence that he has in that
has got him right out front not only
with that [ __ ] but with his fastball
kind of forced their hand to the right
side brian will take it himself shuffles
over
steps in the bag with the left foot
advertent gets him one two
three six start of 2021
is ready to rock he's back in there one
two pitch
swung out and missed strike three and
contreras down on strikes and walker
buellers faced four men
and struck them all out two men out
david body will hear the national anthem
in the background here pretty soon
fastball to the corner strike three
walker bueller
five strikeouts over the first two
innings six
up six down scoreless game in the third
and here's mookie betts
that strikes out swinging second time al
zalai has gotten him that's five
strikeouts for ad barrett alzalei
mueller's got five punch-outs and so
does owls like going into this fourth
inning they're going to be looking for
that picture let's establish heater
early
that pitch right there that slider
excellent another punch out for al zalad
what a way here's turner who walked 3-2
and a miss strikeout number seven that's
the exact same pitch that he was able to
get corey seeger on it's that slider
that starts like it's gonna be a strike
delivers a two on to muncie
left center field back towards the gap
in the wall and
gone opposite field home run
max muncie his second game in a row with
a long ball and the dodgers strike first
number five of the season for muncie
first hit of the game produces the first
run for the dodgers
it's a fastball on the outer half max
went deep to right field
as we move to the bottom of the fourth
inning one nothing dodgers
chris bryant to face walker bueller
bounces it towards seeger as well he
charges throws and gets him two up and
two down trey is taking his time
climbing in there as bueller
waits for him his sixth strikeout
on the slider just an eight pitch inning
for walker mueller
dodgers in front one nothing two and two
on taylor
to tune taylor smacks it into right
field of base hit
a lead off single and the dodgers with
the lead off man aboard
gavin lux the hit one out and one on for
the dodgers a one-nothing lead
to go away from him again he had the
called strike out there so in the back
of his mind he's going to protect that
part of the plate he does more than
protect out there
he laces the ball down the left field
line this is his first extra base hit
then coming back from
the wrist issues matt duffy at the blade
playing third base tonight for the cubs
the pitch
this is line to right field it'll drop
in in front of bets for a base hit
duffy is two for two a two out single
here in the fifth inning cubs have
gotten so many contributions
from the complementary pieces that they
added during the offseason maristnik
swings hits one to
deep left center field look up this
is gone jake mariznick ties up the game
a two run shot two to two
cubs and dodgers here in the bottom half
of the fifth inning
how's that for complementary pieces z
nick mariznick pressing for more playing
time the way he has been performing in
an
ambush from the bottom of the batting
order after two quick outs
single duffy long ball mariznick
and we are not enough hold an
opportunity for the dodgers here tied at
two in the sixth inning they've got the
bases loaded with nobody out
ryan tapira comes on for will smith
smith hits the bottom here to center
field back goes mauriznick with just
enough
room but it'll bring home the go-ahead
ride
everybody advances ball kicks away
momentarily but turner hangs on
the dodgers have retaken the lead and a
sacrifice fly from
will smith and with one out the cubs
have two men in scoring position
as the cubs now threatening the bottom
of the six 3-2 dodgers
and wilson contreras who struck out
twice tonight
he got him the slider to get contreras
a huge second out and a strikeout for
walker bueller
eighth strikeout of the game for walker
bueller
and still working with two on and two
out hayward at the plate
mueller to hayward with a 2-2 pitch
swung on another broken bat roller up
the middle right there is seeger he
throws onto first to get him
and the cubs strand two so walker
bueller gets out of the jam
trying and on guarding a one-run lead's
trying
rounded to the right side they get one
safe at first run comes in and it's
three three so one time right now max
this is the time
with two on and two out honestly hoping
to see a good one from the right-hander
mills home one one
month he drives about a left center
field that is against the ivy
looks in the score tarters headed home
relay from baez
and the dodgers do get one here at the
tent bottom of the tenth inning ken lee
chancellor to try to close this one
two on nobody out nobody like to do
damage more
in this ball game than jack peterson the
x dodger
high and deep right field bets back back
some more and the
park's going to hold it tagging from
third
is duffy jack peterson a sac fly he
just missed it and the disbelief wow
i mean he full-on looked at the dugout
so they go back-to-back
intentional walks to load the bases up
to put wilson contreras into the
spotlight
ground is short zigger to second one
and the game keeps on moving first and
third and matt
baiden now that double play is in order
and the pitch on the way
ground ball to rizzo gloves it throws to
second they get one
and the tag there in time did rizzo not
step on the bag at first
not so this is going to cost the cubs a
run
give the dodgers one so it's a force out
not a tag out at second
and now it'll be left up to matt duffy
lefty fires
line drive banks hit centerfield
contreras around third
he's headed to the plate matt duffy
delivers
it's 5-5 in the 11th
and it sets it up anthony rizzo the
pitch to rizzo
bounced to the left side it gets through
definitely around
third into score comes win
anthony rizzo walks it off